I shot a ton of CEOs. 12 covers.
This snake thing has got to be
the craziest origin story
I've ever heard.
Honestly, it was boring
compared to what came next.
We started our farm
in coastal Florida.
We are thriving here!
We're prepared to purchase
your entire crop.
What do you say?
Back! Back! Everyone back!
Jillian, back desk now!
I sign here.
We’re in business! No backsies!
The second our business
got even a tiny bit of success,
people showed up
trying to take it.
I want to talk to you
about a proposition.
What happens if I say no?
Come on.
What the hell?
Did you feed the gator?
Well, the thing
about Buttercup—
Don't name him!
And definitely not Buttercup!
This creepy swamp family.
They screwed me over.
We split the profits.
80/20.
Vanessa and Camille are
counting on me.
I'd rather keep it aboveboard.
Who are you?
I’m with the state of Florida.
We’re shuttin’ you down.
Don’t worry, guys.
You’ll keep getting paid.
And Margarita Monday
is still on.
You can't promise them that.
I already juiced
the limes, Craig!
This is my farm. That I own!
Shut up!
I promise. There’s a plan.
It won't be pretty.
Let's go. Suit up.
Dolores!
You have to wear underwear
in the common areas.
The bathroom is a common
area and I’m naked there.
Your rule makes no sense.
We are building
a business here.
No crimes, no scams.
It's time we escalate
this situation.
Sometimes in business,
people get hurt.
What was that?
Yeah! That was crazy!
Do you think I might be
repressing some anger?
Yes, Jillian, I do think so!